i know it's hard for these kids because
you know i know what i went through
but it's a lot tougher now with the way
society is now
it's just sorry to see the young boys
and girls come off the ice crying
because of racial slurs
[Music]
when i get the chance to talk to these
boys and girls on the ice or
by a phone or even in person i just try
and tell them that
names will never hurt you unless you let
them
just play hockey play your game and
don't worry about anything else
because it's going to take a lot of time
before people just look at a person for
who they are
willie found out and he called me a few
days later i was actually in school
and he just talked to me and asked me a
few questions what happened
how to make you feel when he called us
that was kind of like oh i'm talking to
william like this is pretty cool
it wasn't just because he had to call us
he wanted to call us
and he wanted to help us with this
situation
and then there's also an incident like
two weeks ago where someone told me to
go back to mexico
which i don't really know but later that
game it ended up being a tie
3-3 after the third period and then the
ot
i ended up scoring the ot winner it just
goes to show like
you can respond to that from your
actions and not words i guess like on
the ice
not actions by like slashing everywhere
but like actions like scoring
or making a good play and stuff like
that
willie's legacy is important to
celebrate right now because
we live in a society now where very
rapidly it's become acceptable to be
unkind
and i think it's very important that we
honor
somebody like willie because willie is
the complete opposite
he is very kind and he has helped my
boys
to become kinder people
there's a big push to get willie into
the hall of fame and i think he really
deserves to be there
because he has done a lot for hockey
there i am right there yeah with the
bronze uniform mom
and here i am here i am here this had to
be the 1950
53 team i think i was 18's
that's my brother richard uh his
nickname was coo
he's the one that taught me a lot about
hockey and
the 21 years i played pearl i had to
credit my brother
for all the things that he had taught me
it was my older brother who was my
mentor he loved the game of hockey
zombies over at the rings and watching
me play
he taught me so many things that i
needed to know sometimes in practice
he would check me so hard that tears
would come to my eyes but he always said
that
you'll be hit a lot harder than this if
you get into the pro ranks and
uh he was right well i went up in the
stands a couple of times
[Music]
but it um i obviously i always tried to
keep it on the ice you know but
there are there were some incidents that
you had to just show them that hey
you're not going to take this type of
abuse oh ray
the pastor right in front of the net
brewer trying to bring it out
in 1961 i was playing against the
chicago blackhawks and
this player comes and gives me a
two-hander across the ankles and
he made a couple racial remarks comes
out
from my blind side and i can't see him
and he holds about six inches out of his
stick and he buttons me in the
in the mouth not splits my nose splits
my lip knocks my two front teeth out
[Music]
he just stood there and laughed both
benches emptied
we were both thrown out of the game
i went in the dress room and after they
stitched me up
i wanted to come back out and sit on the
bench with the players but the fans were
so i irate that there could be bodily
harm to me so
i remained in the dress room the entire
game
[Music]
i meditated for a few minutes
do i really want to continue playing and
go through this abuse every game
[Music]
but then i told myself that if i leave
the league i'm going to leave it because
i don't have the skills and the ability
to play anymore
i'm not going to leave it because the
racism and the prejudice and
the bigotry and the ignorance of not
only players on the opposition but
fans in the stands
you